braves have the right guy on the mound
charlie's going for his 11th win and
he's been electric over his last five
decisions
absolutely it all starts with that guy
in the hill kyle miller yesterday had a
great game pitched out of a jam or two
charlie the ace of the staff in my
opinion lately has really thrown well
made a mechanical adjustment to get
everything on track going to home plate
since then he has been fantastic tyrone
taylor the brewers left fielder high fly
ball to left no carry to that duvall
backs up just a touch
and it does carry out a bit to the
warning track and taylor's retired for
out number one morton off to a good
start omar nervaez the milwaukee catcher
and a right field but
solaire is there hasn't played much
outfield over the american league and
wouldn't you know it he gets another
chance in the first inning like he did
last night oh two up two down just
getting started this afternoon there's
willie adams
as adama's first pitch hacking to fly
ball head back in a deep right center
field heredia going back and that's out
of here william thomas
home run number 13 as a brewer and the
crew jumping out to a one-nothing lead
yeah just what they needed offense a
little bit flat last night charlie
morton starting him out with a slider he
weighed it back nicely taking it to
right center
there's your lead check it out
kind of a spinner up there at 88 miles
an hour didn't do a whole lot and
william dominance able to take advantage
of that and give the brewers a lead yeah
powerball home run count as we mentioned
13 now with the brewers 18 overall this
season eduardo escobar this is his third
game with milwaukee as freddie freeman
scoops that up adamus with a solo home
run now the braves go to work against
brett anderson a soft tossing lefty is
on the mount next collecting brett
anderson yeah real good as last time
matt it was a win on the road trip
against a pirate six innings three hits
no runs in a
nine to nothing brewers victory making
start number four career
against the braves we'll face ozzie
albees and going after the first pitch
fred anderson a ground ball pitcher gets
one right away escobar takes care of it
one pitch one out and there's jorge
solaire
a good debut last night for the braves
three hits one-two pitch to solaire and
a curveball into left field and
running it down for out number two is
tyrone taylor two up two down for
freddie freeman
there's a liner into the shift and right
there is
out number three balls right there
against brett anderson but they all
found gloves early for atlanta it's
gonna be a very exciting final two
months
here in atlanta
as jackie bradley jr hits one toward
left duval into the corner at the wall
he got there right at the 335 side good
play and bradley's retired for route
number one that's respect he had to go a
long way to catch that ball he did and
he ran a straight line right to the ball
and now again i say adam duval does not
get enough credit as a defender out
there he has been really good the last
couple of years for the braves as
morton's got anderson who doesn't have a
hit yet this year and that should
continue if heredia catches this and he
does two outs six up six down and back
to the top tyrone taylor
this one's chopped toward third big hop
for riley long toss across is in time
and charlie morton's on a roll three out
six pitches and heredi is at second now
for kevin smith
[Applause]
as he faces charlie morton 0-2 pitch
and there you go there's a strikeout and
that is out number two here in the third
a couple of curve balls with a fast ball
in between them two men out top of the
order ozzy all these to the play
on the ground adamus backhand stab and
the pick frontalez
that's sweet yeah this guy
rowdy teles we've talked about his
hitting
do a little work defensively
oh adamus he can play some short omar
narayan he's over one with a fly out to
right field had a deep fly to right back
in the first inning
rocking out towards center field already
a long run he's gonna get there good
play narvaez flies out for the second
time and that's a perfect example right
there already on his toes because he
knows he's throwing a lot of strikes
you're going to be ready for everything
good jump
look at that straight line ewa the x
drill perfect example no complaints
about the outfield defense no not at all
there's adamus sway again a miss morton
wins that battle gets a little revenge
that's his second strikeout and nine up
nine down doing the fourth inning i
think it might have been don drysdale
that set up hank aaron trying to sneak a
fastball by him was like trying to sneak
the sunrise past a rooster two down now
for escobar
popped up towards the left escobar flies
out to duvall charlie morton's rolling
he set down 10 straight jackie bradley
jr with runners in scoring position 2-1
pitch fastball on the ground all these
fields the play is at first but a run is
in that'll work rbi ground ball from
jackie bradley junior kane is in it's a
two-nothing game taylor leading off
today for the first time in this series
another hook three straight got him
looking four strikeouts for charlie
morton that's how the sixth inning
starts charlie's pitched great he's
giving up just three hits but the braves
offense has been silenced to this point
two and two as narvaez stays alive
there's the hook and three straight
strikeouts for morton that's five in the
game and now it sets up the adamus match
up
charlie morton just struck out the side
he's punched out four straight and we
head to the home sixth so we'll see how
it unfolds here braves need a two out
hit they've got two aboard in the sixth
inning up the middle and into center
field base hit the braves are on the
board riley comes through with two outs
and for the moment the decision
backfires riley couldn't make contact
against anderson he brings home aussie
albies to make it a 2-1 game and you
better believe right there paul he
throws him a slider first pitch for a
ball throws him the fastball and he
comes back with that slaughter austin
riley did a terrific job probably
looking for that pitch
and was able to get that ball up the
middle that was the slaughter that was
running away from him loved it riley
contending for nl player of the month
hot as the sun a couple of singles off
devon williams in the eighth inning and
dansby swanson he struck him out gotta
want to change up for out number two
such a difference when you put it where
you want it
i mean you leave them up in the zone
they become hittable down here
good luck to you
once and got williams back in that count
chasing that high fastball then put him
away with a couple of change-ups adam
duvall two on two out in a one-run game
williams delivers he struck him out
yes sir be fired up stranding the tying
run in scoring position in the bottom of
the eighth two outs basis empty is hater
trying to nail down his 22nd save of the
year payoff pitch he struck him out
looking game over back to the gas for
josh hader who nails down his 22nd save
of the year final this afternoon 2-1